neil and james search a shipwreck
for the mega shark big bull and other
large bull sharks that may be
her descendants i'm good over here
bull sharks have a pac-like mentality
and swarm around possible food
they surround the divers
neil and james nestle into the wreck for
protection
james two lasers work like an electronic
ruler
to confirm the size of the bulls
if one is close to 10 feet long it could
be
big bull possibly the largest shark
alive
multiplying the six inch long distance
of the lasers
they estimate that this shark is young
from snout to the curve of the tail
a little over five feet long
but nearby
a giant pushing nine feet
only inches smaller than big bull was in
2012.
they get more measurements awesome
but the strong current with this many
sharks
turns this dive dangerous
this card is gonna carry me to england
by the way
how about that that was epic no it's a
bunch of
some nice size bulls not as big as big
bull but i feel really good about this
it's a good starting point
to take you search the next level
they've confirmed bulls
as large as those reported by local
divers and fishermen
while they're not quite the size of big
bull this is
her territory
and if neil's theory is right the sharks
here
may be her offspring
[Music]
you